Bill Shatner Bill Shatner hello so years
ago yeah
are you listening no you didn't you did
an eye thing no I'm drinking I'm
thinking about it no but you look on the
ground not your glass I'm listening are
you really I'm active listening okay so
um well remember the Kim Jong-un which
part where they told me I had to play oh
so I got to go back a little bit okay so
Billboard Awards goes can you play Kim
Jong-un that's right so I go okay so
they go come to Vegas so they had me in
Kim Jong-un in the audience and uh and
D.L Hughley was supposed to do a bit
with me on stage but he forgot to men do
it so I just sat there in the audience
and that didn't do nothing
yeah I sat there all show and he didn't
do it and I'm sitting there now people
are going why the [__] is this guy
sitting here it's Kim Jong-un all right
so that's what happened so the year
later I just want you to know that in
telling the story as a superior
Storyteller than you like I'm better
than you no I know I am I know you I
know him yeah come on this is one of my
favorite stories you've ever told
it already sets up so this is a great
setup because D.L Hughley forgot now you
look like a [__] Luna this is a
really great setup to a story because
now you look like some lunatic dresses
right and then and then Abby my manager
was sitting behind me oh and when will
when when
um he forgot to do it she kept saying
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I'm sorry oh
my in my ear
the whole show my manager was right
behind me I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
because she knew I was living because I
had to put Beyond Prosperity do we have
a visual of you as Kim Jong-un is this
it no that was Kim Jong-il oh oh well
differently you play them so differently
they look like this different different
like I mean uh point of view what was
your motivation between Kimberly so
anyway so then a year later billboard
Kim Jong [__] One Time by making a Kim
Jong joke wait what was it what was it I
said can you believe how arrogant in
this guy to name all his kids with his
first name Kim Ah that's why yeah yeah
that's his last name last name yeah no
[__] I found that out the hard way how
would you not know that he's in Twitter
I didn't know I I didn't realize
your last name at first Asians lit me up
I had to delete the comment and then
they oh then they weren't done with me
oh no we're not they were done with me
they were like they were like oh you
can't just delete the comments [__] boy
we know what you meant and I thought I
really thought he named his kids Kim
Jong-un and then like Albert Charles
Christ you're the first ever Charles
Christ you're the second
yeah yeah yeah yeah anyway keep going
can I finish I'm dying so a year later
the Billboard Awards goes we're gonna
make it up too okay so I go what is that
like we know you love Star Trek okay
[__] yeah keep talking and they go well
how about a sketch with you and William
Shatner
do I have to fly to Vegas again yeah
so I fly to Vegas he's not there for
rehearsal it's just me at a [__]
poker table and we have some dialogue we
get a tiff me and William Shatner
then he finally arrives he walks in the
tent
and he looks at everyone he looked
towards me you're out you're out you're
out and and then they put me out of the
tent and I go what happened yeah he just
wants to do his own thing
I go I go home now yeah sorry
that's poor producing right there
I mean would you be mad though yeah
right yeah oh I'd be livid I be livid I
won't I I can't I'm not an actor like
that though I can't you can't put me on
a set and tell me to wait I start
getting really depressed yeah but you do
it nope I don't yes you did it for your
movie no no no it's very different I
started my own movie I can be that lead
of something I can't be cast and then go
sit in this trailer and then we'll come
get you when we're ready for you you've
never done that before I won't no you
have no it won't you must I have no I
haven't no I have obviously I have like
I've done I've never done that per se
kind of but like I can't do uh I'm
trying to show an example Pete what was
the one I recently I'll pull people
aside and go you just you know this is
making me [__] crazy and I'm so
depressed like if Star Wars called they
they would they could cast you as young
Jabba
right when he's like right when he's
just done playing football and he hasn't
gotten into gambling yet yes you know
exactly what I'm talking about right
yeah and he can move you can still move
I can move yeah man it's a young Jabba
they're like we don't even need green
screen
or Prosthetics yeah yeah it's perfect no
keeping this improv it feels good all
right no no no and I'm young Yoda no
you're still Kim Jong-un all right so
anyway and they and they go you're young
you would wait days in a trailer to play
Young Jabba I offered the role of a Jedi
and I turn it down oh that's just so
[__] [__] [__] what is that
real story
yeah he was there what you're a Jedi but
I didn't take it I didn't take the
meeting I didn't take the audition I
didn't take any of it wow why would you
do that that's a [__] doesn't matter
to me I can't I can't I I'm telling you
right now I get physically depressed uh
being like a paid for higher gun it
makes me lose my mind I and I'm not I'm
not I know I'm not good for them and
like and I'm doing it I'm doing it on
something else I said yes to but I but
I'm doing it because of the person
because I go I can find so like I'll put
it through this way if uh if Jonah Hill
who I think is brilliant he's great if
he wanted to work with me and he said
here's the deal you got to sit in a
trailer for 10 hours and you're gonna
work 15 hours a day I do it I'd want to
work with Jonah Hill and I can find a
way out of that depression but if you
say hey man we want you shoot a Miller
Lite commercial and it pays 125 000 or
500 000 yeah and you don't have a
contraction of the of the creative
control you don't you're just gonna be
the guy that shows up rips his shirt off
and kills the Miller Light but we're
gonna need for four days yeah it pays
five hundred thousand dollars yeah I
couldn't do it I couldn't do it because
I know what go I go through I shot
something
I'm trying to think of something Fair
because I don't want to light up anyone
but like in the product light somebody
up no like in the whole setup for this
movie or for promotion I had to shoot
some stuff at some times
um
and I would I would watch uh producers
take I shot something I can't say
anything I can't say any of them I can't
say anything I shot stuff make it up
then uh I shot something for Bud Light
and they said hey
I was a transgender I was a transgender
have you seen it you were that guy yes
I am in a bathtub I get it I saw it I'm
drinking a cold beer the way all of us
should I just can't